first corner drafted the points bet odds
uh are available and uh as always our
odds come from them there's patrick
certain minus 300 the clear favorite jc
horn plus 200 your guy caleb farley plus
1500 looks like the folks in vegas think
that that uh it would be patrick certain
to the cowboys at 10 or maybe to someone
else before then yeah i would think that
that's the first guy off the board you
know clean medical history been coached
by nick saban
you know has
all the attributes you want to me the
one thing you've heard me say
continually about certain is just i wish
he was a little faster you know i do
think he's going to have some issues
matching up man-to-man with the elite
receivers and football the speed guys
that way you know that's to me where
caleb farley
i don't question that at all i've never
seen someone that big run the way caleb
farley does but yeah i think when you
take all into account i think certain is
going to be
the the first guy off the board you know
it'll be interesting it's a good corner
group it really is i think some of these
guys in this this group are a little
overrated for for my money you know
again i don't know how you can rank and
you admit this makes sense to you mike i
don't know how you can rank a corner
like a top 20 pick a top 10 pick that
kind of stuff if they don't run 4-3 you
know the great corners in the history of
the sport run 4-3 or better that you
just go through it that's it how do you
expect them to cover the really fast
receivers in football if they're a tenth
of a second slower and the receivers
you've got to be able to recover heard
you say this before you got to be able
to recover when they make the move when
they exit you thought they were going to
zag you got to have the ability to close
the ground yes that's where i mean i err
on a little bit of just pure speed when
i evaluate corners and i have a decent
history with corners evaluation but but
uh yeah that's that's a it's an
interesting topic and some of these
corners that we even had on the list
there you know they're like they're zone
guys where i'm gonna go you can't put
him on an island he didn't they didn't
even trust them in college to be on an
island and now you're gonna say okay
we're gonna draft him in the top 25
picks like that that to me but doesn't
add up sometimes
the two guys at the top of the odds that
we showed from points bet patrick
certain the second jc horn both the sons
of nfl yeah cool kane's dad was a corner
jc horn's dad joe horn was a receiver
does it
what what is the factor is there a
factor does it count does it matter if
dad was an nfl player i think does that
help a guy i do i think it does help a
guy i think i think the the big thing is
where
coaches front office people
you know they feel comfortable and wait
this guy grew up in this he knows what
life is like in the nfl he knows what to
expect and you know more times than not
knows what it takes to be a professional
and play in the league i think that's
the positives you know they realize okay
more times than not it's like hey this
guy grew up in this he's a gym rat this
is what he likes to do he knows
everything about the sport there's going
to be no shocks he understands the
business everything like that i think
that's the value that you know coaches
and gm's look at with you know sons of
ex-players and things like that
ahsante samuel jr also
in the draft he was uh asante senior was
a patriots
out when eagles got a huge contract uh
last year antoine winfield junior who i
i thought should have gone higher than
he did
get him and he ends up being a key
member of that defense that's another
reason
and and we know how the cycle works a
guy comes in
his dad played he does really well all
of a sudden more attractive go back to
2004 quarterback gets drafted his dad
was a really good quarterback he doesn't
do so well all of a sudden the son of a
player isn't as attractive
well because you said 2004 i was drafted
in 2003. i thought you were talking
about eli i was like what is he talking
about eli
i'm talking about the 2004 draft because
it was a 2003 draft where you entered
the league oh by the way they're saying
oh yeah right about it right forget
about the son of the guy who played so
yeah sorry sorry um all right let's move
on who will be the first defender
drafted regardless of position what does
points bet say about that drum roll
please
certain over under for him 10 and a half
michael parsons 12 and a half for him
there's horn at 13 and a half quid he
paid the edge rusher from michigan 16
and a half christian bar more 23 and a
half gregory rousseau
30 and a half uh
it's so hard to tell this year yeah it
really is there's none of these that
jump off to me is wrong or right
we just don't know we just don't know i
think certain is the one that's the most
intriguing because
like you said if he's there at 10
i i i
it seems like the cowboys would slash
should take him so i would go under on
him for the rest who the hell knows yeah
no i mean i'm with you listen the one i
i don't jc horn you know we were just
talking about i i like him a lot
you know i i i see a lot of things like
that here recently where it's top 15 top
20. i'm shocked by that i i really am
i'm shocked good player but you know he
would be that guy again that i would say
i don't know if the speed is quite
special enough for me to take him in the
top 20 and think he's going to lock down
like top end receivers
it's the top two guys of the list for me
mike as far as the first two defenders
off the board we talked about the
cowboys right with certain at 10 and all
of that so that's certainly a
possibility you know i brought up the
broncos before in that conversation
about a team that could be looking
defense i look at them at nine to think
hey vic fangio
came from the 49ers what did he have
there navarro bowman patrick willis he
went to the chicago bears defensive
coordinator they signed danny trevathan
drafted roquan smith in the top ten
i they don't have a they the middle
linebacker is really probably the most
glaring
need on their football team michael
parsons is that guy i look at to go he
could go number nine you know he he's
he's too special of a specimen he's
right up there with the devin bushes and
the devon whites of the world who we saw
about go in the top 10 or 11 you know
what two years ago so i could see him
being the first guy off the board of the
broncos at number nine i wouldn't be
shocked by that
here's my my open plea yeah jc horn
right wherever he lands wherever he
plays
get a couple of old flip phones yeah put
him under the goal post every game you
get fined we will raise the money we
will do the gofundme to raise the money
for the fun i know that that no one else
is supposed to pay the fine
fine
we will raise the money to pay the fine
and you actually got to call dad that's
the other part of it too you got to go
fish out the phone and call dad after
scoring your first nfl touchdown it may
take a while playing defense but i think
it's worth it well and it would be money
well spent especially since it would be
someone else's money that would be
raising to pay for that fine yeah well
you're right i mean yeah it would be
really cool hey
he is a stud
as far as his body makeup his strength
his physicality his attitude i mean i
love that aspect of him he's got a
no-nonsense in-your-face type of style
that i do love there's no doubt it'd be
cool if he did do that at some point in
his career you know flip phone i guess
he could still buy him or maybe he just
you know iphones it right he's got
gloves on it's going to be hard to dial
in the flip phone he could just pick up
the iphone and say hey siri call dad and
that might be a cool thing to do so i'm
with you there i hope he infuses that
into a celebration at some point
he's got to get nike to make him a set
of gloves that maybe has just tiny
the different material so you can still
punch out on the phone but either way
either way we hope that at some point
there will be an homage to what his dad
did all those years ago although it was
a significant find a very significant
find that was imposed on joe horn how
many defenders go in the first half of
the draft let's see what point do we
have a points bet odds on that or or no
do we no just just curiosity yeah look i
i think we may not see any until 10.
after that i don't know four is it is
four too high what's he over how about
over under a three and a half what are
you taking three and a half that's a
good topic okay that's a good one there
um
man
i would say
i i'm gonna go i'll go over did you say
three and a half i'll go over three and
a half i'm gonna say i'm gonna say four
but that man it's dicey when you sit
there and look at that especially you go
the top half of the draft
your vikings football team i would think
would be thinking defense right i i
would think the giants are thinking
defense cowboys broncos those are the
four i'm kind of leaning on i don't know
about you know the cardinals the
chargers the eagles they could go a lot
of different ways there so i'll go in
with the over as far as if you set it at
three and a half
what do you think what do you think the
broncos do if justin fields is there at
nine
that's like again one of those where you
brought it up earlier right where it's
like
wait the coaching staff's butts could be
on the hot seat the personnel people
just got there and might be going we're
looking in the future we don't care that
your butt's hot on the seat whatever
there so that's where
it's a it's a tough decision that way
man
i would just think with where they are
as an organization right now i if i'm
denver i'm staying with drew locke and
i'm calling the 49ers and trying to get
jimmy garoppolo that's what i'm trying
to do right now that would be that would
be my play if i'm them you know again i
i never teddy i'd want teddy okay or him
too either way either one that type of
guy um
again i'm not a i'm not a big believer
and justin fields is a top 10 pick i'm
not i've said that from the start i
really think he's somewhere between 20
and 32 for me there's some issues in his
game that i'm just not sold that are
they're fixable and that would scare the
hell out of me so um
yeah that's what i'll say about the
broncos thing to remember about the
broncos dynamic can you hit the nail on
the head vic fangio may be on the hot
seat george payton the new gm isn't
and payton ascended to this job after
years of being in the nfl he passed on
opportunities to interview for other gm
jobs he surely has a list
of coaches he's been scouting when
you're a scout you're not just scouting
players you're scouting coaches he's got
a list of coaches he wants to hire he's
already got it he comes to the job with
that list and unless coincidentally vic
fangio is number one on the list or
somewhere in the top five peyton's not
going to care if fangio ends up getting
fired after this year a lot of times
when you get a new gm when you have an
existence buys you an extra year once
yeah he wants right to get that coach
out and you're right it gives you a
grace period because you're not judged
until you get your coach exactly now now
if your team ends up pretty good then
you're stuck with that guy for a few
years like like jerry angelo was with
dick geron all those years ago when
angelo wanted to pivot to nick saban or
lovey smith and and geron won the
division so it ended up being a
three-year forced marriage but yeah
peyton isn't going to care unless vic
fangio is at or near the top of george
payton's list of coaches that that he's
been waiting to work with yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports